das war die unglaubliche nachricht
gestern die usa steigen aus dem
weltklimavertrag aus trump will mehr co2
in die luft warten meint seine wähler
und anderen arbeiter in der kohle gas
und erdöl industrie arbeitsplätze
brauchen und das weltklima abkommen die
usa benachteiligt sind mal wieder fake
news oder ich würde sagen quatsch mit
soße
wie der us präsident ihr verbreitet wie
warum wieso und was die folgen sind
jetzt in science fiction herzlich
willkommen
ja unglaublich war gestern auch der
deutsche web video preis bürger zu haben
versteht die welt nicht mehr bzw er hat
sie noch nie verstanden
er ist an anhänger extrem einfacher
denkmodelle die aber einfach so nicht
funktionieren und er versteht politik
nicht weil er jetzt das weltklima
abkommen neu verhandeln wir dabei gibt
es da gar nicht so ferne
nicht nur weil es freiwillige
selbstverpflichtungen sind sondern auch
weil sich der rest der welt gegen die
usa stellt und das ist politisch ein
riesenproblem das amt verursacht hat der
rest der welt steht hier gegen die usa
zusammen und sogar zahlreiche us
bundesstaaten wie kalifornien florida
oder new york wollen das weltklima vom
100 amerikanische firmen wiki ölkonzern
exxonmobil facebook apple microsoft
ettler wind gegen ausgesetzt der
bürgermeister von fritz box die stadt
die trump explizit in seiner ansprache
genannt hatte hat getwittert dass sich
seine stadt freiwillig den richtlinien
des weltklimavertrags folgen er ist also
politisch eine riesige blödheit die aber
leider folgen haben wird gerade wurde
bekannt dass das antarktische eis
anfängt viel stärker zu schmelzen
bisher hatte sich gegen die erderwärmung
im wahrsten sinne des wortes gestimmt
aber jetzt schmilzt der widerstand in
form von schützenden schelfeis vor der
antarktischen küste langsam dahin warme
wasser strömung unter dem eis bringen es
immer stärker zum schmelzen
die eismassen die jetzt anfangen zu
schmelzen werden am ende einen anstieg
des meeresspiegels von 58 metern
verursachen moment 58 meter höheren
meeresspiegel
grund sind die wahnsinnigen eis was am 7
das läppert sich einfach wenn fünf
kilometer dicke eis ins meer fliesst die
konsequenzen werden also schlimm sein
klimaforscher rechnen mit 0,3 grad
höheren temperaturen für den fall dass
die usa den ausstieg durch den wobei die
nachteile für die usa deutlich die
vorteile überwiegen werden durch den
ausstieg wahrscheinlich kaum
arbeitsplätze schaffen
regenerative energie ist inzwischen oft
billiger als fossile brennstoffe wie öl
gas und kohle müssen immer aufwendiger
und umwelt schädigen abgebaut werden wie
zum beispiel beim fracking bei dem öl
aus tief liegenden gesteinsschichten
gepresst wird das mit chemikalien
verbunden ist und unkontrolliert
austritt von gas zum beispiel aus dem
wasser hin das ist schon verrückt was
für uns menschen zugemutet zudem macht
es überhaupt keinen sinn hier neue
technologien zu entwickeln
bei dir weltweit niemand haben will im
gegenteil die usa kommen hier industrie
also ihre industrie von der weltweiten
entwicklung ab wie es so schön heißt wer
nicht mit der zeit geht geht mit der
zeit spricht er nicht vorne bei den
innovationen dabei ist der wird als
mitarbeiter irgendwann entlassen weil es
für ein land bedeutet das ist kaum
absehbar
aber die verelendung ist damit auf jeden
fall nicht aufzuhalten sondern nimmt
eher noch zu dass es auch anders geht da
für deutschland gezeigt im nächsten jahr
2018 wird die letzte kohle zeche im
ruhrgebiet mit prosper-haniel in bottrop
geschlossen und die arbeitslosigkeit in
deutschland ist auf dem niedrigsten
stand seit fast 20 jahren wirst du
einfach
deutschland ist vorreiter bei den
regenerativen energien und knapp 400.000
menschen arbeiten hier in diesem bereich
die usa werden so den anschluss
verlieren und nicht nur von deutschland
sondern auch von china und zahlreichen
anderen ländern überholt werden wie
viele politiker gestern festgestellt
haben
die wird nicht amerika great ärgern
gemacht sondern künstlich geschrumpft es
ist so bescheuert wie beim drechsel
schädigt sich hier ein land massiv
selbst und noch etwas trägt dazu bei mit
dem der klima abkommen sind erhebliche
investitionen in entwicklungsländern zur
senkung deren co2 ausstoß geplant der
wind die usa jetzt raus und verlieren
aufträge in milliarden-höhe für ihre
industrie
zudem ist mit strafzöllen für die usa zu
rechnen denn das hat der rest der welt
bereits für die länder diskutiert die
aus während kommen harte zeiten auf die
usa zunichte von ungefähr hat ihnen
macht den ausstieg heftig kritisiert und
sich aus sams beraterteam verabschiedet
eppler wird erheblich durch diesen
beschluss geschrieben aber noch ist
nicht aller tage abend der von tram
gewählte weg dauert einige zeit und wir
hoffen auf einen umschwung oder in gut
drei jahren auf einen neuen präsidenten
oder eine neue präsidentin die diesen
beschluss sofort wieder kaffee zum mal
was da noch so alles passieren wird da
ist der drops sicher noch lange nicht
schluss unser nächstes thema
krankheitserreger werden frei also sind
wirklich gefährlich grüne antarktis und
der steigende mehr geschrieben dass
hat alles wird der weltweiten
eisschmelze zu tun und darüber gibt es
bald ein video irrt wenn er das nicht
verpassen wollte das wird mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den auf
die glocke hier geht es weiter mit den
spannenden videos bei pixum sind zum
thema klimawandel kauf klicken von
ansonsten distanz bleibt